a modern-day mona lisa that's how the
chairman of christie's is describing a
portrait of marilyn monroe andy warhol's
shot sage blue maryland is up for
auction one in a series the first to be
auctioned off in nearly 25 years
warhol created the iconic silkscreen
image of monroe after the actress died
of a sleeping pill overdose in 1962.
some 60 years later the public is still
fascinated by her life and death
warhol's genius is because he
encapsulated the tragedy and the
disaster of maryland the suicide after
having the most amazing life being the
most beautiful woman the piece comes
from the private collection of thomas
and doris amman and is the centerpiece
of the auction house's marquee sales
week
warhol's maryland is expected to shatter
records for contemporary art when it
goes up for auction on monday bringing
in the realm of 200 million dollars or
more instantly putting its buyer in an
elite class of collectors
there's no regent that is completely
disinterested it also tells you
something the impending sale is
attracting international interest
why is this piece expected to fetch more
than any other contemporary art piece in
history in this case you get
a beautiful painting by one of the
greatest artists of art history
and you get the most famous painting of
this artist to show the beauty and the
disaster at the same time no other
painting
has ever shown this so well
and perhaps no other painting has been
so well poised to capitalize on
post-pandemic pent-up demand to see and
purchase art
kristin salumi al jazeera new york